bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans les 7 8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite à le sommaire de votre magazine
jo-2016 des événements réaliser une
version exceptionnelle les sportifs ont
remporté 11 médailles cet été à rio dont
trois en or autour sur ses performances
dans cette émission football c'est et la
reprise ce week-end en championnat pour
la plupart des clubs hubinois en
excellence mort pas joué ce dimanche
contre le pec à domicile la rencontre
s'est terminée par un match nul
spectaculaire 3 buts partout résumé à
suivre karting est immédiat s'agit
seulement de 7 ans est un as du volant
le duo pop 3 vient de remporter le
championnat de france la coupe de france
cet été
sportif est l'un des pilotes les plus
prometteurs de sa génération son
portrait dans le 7-8 sport je vous
disais à dans les titres les jeux
olympiques auront été un cru
exceptionnel pour les sportifs et
villeroy 11 médailles dont trois en or
ont été remportés par les athlètes du
département
retour sur ses performances et xavier
vallat pour le montage une moisson de
médailles aux yeux pour les sportifs
heavy loi les athlètes auront porté au
total onze médailles 3 or 3 en argent et
5 en bronze à rio symbole de ce cru
exceptionnel dans la délégation heavy
l'oise le boxeur tony yoka originaires
de chanteloup les vignes sportif a
décroché l'or dans la catégorie super
lourd très fier de moi qu'est-ce que je
commençais chaput le veut parce que
justin qui prennent vie j'aimais le pnb
à la télé mais
je ne dirais pas que ça qui est comme
moi les deux sportifs ont navires ont
pas de médaille d'or mais une troisième
place pour thomas barrau que le sportif
de 28 ans licencié au cercle nautique de
versailles a décroché le bronze avec ses
coéquipiers sur le quatre sans barreur
poids léger derrière la suisse et le
danemark
ça a été une expérience globalement
satisfaisante on va pas dire le
contraire
quand on voit ce que j'ai autour du cou
aujourd'hui ça a été des jo différent de
ce que j'avais connu en même temps je
n'ai pas beaucoup d'expérience je
connaissais que ceux de londres en 2012
on avait la volonté on savait que
c'était possible qu'on avait le talent
et les capacités de le faire donc très
content d'y être
le délit de bronze également les
pistards de l'équipe de france ont
quitté rio avec un goût amer favoris des
épreuves ligne matin françois pervis
grégory baugé originaire de maisons
laffitte et le plaisir one michael
d'almeida ont échoué dans leur quête de
l'or olympique en individuel sur la
vitesse et le keirin
une déception pour le clan français
chaque fois qu'une déception
on l'attendait le moins et pourquoi pas
mais aussi et puis même si on doutait
bien que la petite partie de sa lecture
c'est quand même allé moi finale gagnée
2 et finalement on fait troisième c'est
bien mais si tu fais pas suffisant dans
les sports collectifs laurie salon
d'origine a de poissy a réussi l'exploit
de décrocher deux médailles d'argent
avec l'équipe de france de hand
une première historique pour le football
féminin français au parcours en
balistique et la gfa g pour une grande
fierté en fierté de devenir de notre
faim là où j'ai repensé à tout cet
argent
le rêve d'une vie qui s'accroupit la
parenthèse se referme pour les sportifs
évinois les athlètes ont désormais
quatre ans pour s'entraîner afin
d'améliorer les résultats obtenus en
terre carioca rendez-vous à tokyo en
2020 vous l'avez vu dans le reportage
libinois toyota a conquis le coeur des
français pendant les jeux olympiques de
rio cet été mais n'a pas été le seul
hubinois boxer à s'illustrer pour la
compétition la france a collecté à six
médailles dont deux en or pendant cette
olympiade des résultats qui devraient se
faire ressentir sur le terrain en terme
de licenciés le boxing club de saint
quentin en yvelines s'attend à
accueillir 40 % de boxer supplémentaire
pour cette nouvelle saison
on écoute les réactions j'ai beaucoup de
coûteux les fonds de gens
énormément je pense qu'on va difficile
vu la taille de la salle
mais en termes d'effectifs pendant
l'année à peu près 120 licenciés on peut
employer villes du bénin après faut
pousser les murs généralement légers ça
ça a pris plus quand même pas mal de
de sensations pour ceux qui regardent et
ensuite il va forcément essayer donc je
parle bien là ça va ramer dur
de leur côté les jeux paralympiques
débutent à rio ce mac os 10 dureront
jusqu'au à 18 septembre dans la cité à
gré vers des alibis noah participera
cette compétition pour la deuxième fois
après pékin cela mais radius originaire
du vésinet le sportif paralysé
partiellement du côté gauche participera
1500 m dans la catégorie des 38 samedi
10 septembre
objectif une médaille nous avons joint
par téléphone le champion juste avant
son départ pour le brésil
d'un point de vue personnel on a pu
matières chères têtes sait déjà c'est de
représenter la france
derrière de représenter l'athlétisme et
la discipline qui elle donne une chance
que je suis toujours le représentant est
derrière barrios et c'est après on voit
que ce continent sud-américain donc si
vous tapez fois football à présent
c'était la reprise ce week-end en
championnat pour la plupart des clubs et
finement en excellence mens pas je vais
à ce dimanche contre le pec à domicile
la rencontre s'est terminée par un
spectaculaire 3 but partout je ne savais
jamais un pendage vainqueur de la coupe
des civils tôt d'une septième place en
championnat lors de la saison 2015-2016
laisse maupas commence par un match nul
est ce un continent ont été tenus en
échec 3 buts partout par le père qu'à
l'occasion de la première journée du
championnat excellence demeure passe
bien mais l'important 3 en seconde
période avant de s'écrouler en fin de
match dessus parce que ils descendent de
péage donc on s'attendait à voir une
grosse équipe
puis finalement je me suis trouvé enfin
on s'est trouvés dessus sur ce match
donc le frustré que l'on n'ait pas
réussi à gagner ce match donc après ces
premiers matches on aura d'autres
matches à jouer c'est physique abéché
est puis les deux pas de lucidité et
hans est remonté à 3 partout pour lancer
sa saison les verts devront s'imposer le
dimanche 18 septembre sur le terrain
douilles
la saison va donner quoi tous ont eu
lieu jusque là vous parler aujourd'hui
d'abus potentiels et l'équilibré de ces
lois
d'après quelques boissons et bonnie tout
est possible at elle ainsi que
l'excellence et chez les capitales
le clip qui sont là aussi pour bébé
voilà donc que les organes j'espère
qu'on sera à venir surtout les valeurs
basses qui reste encore à son butin on
espère monter j'espère on va prendre les
matches match par match et on verra
comment ça va se passer mais on a un bel
effectif qui fait qu'on pourra jouer la
montée à l'issue de cette première
journée lors pas occupe la 7e place du
classement messieurs championnat
excellence elle deux équipes
son nom ne vous dit peut-être rien mais
il pourrait devenir dans quelques années
la future superstar de la formule 1 jim
elias âgé de seulement à 7 ans est un as
du volant
le but en comptant vers le remporter le
championnat de france et la coupe de
france cet été
un reportage mettez à toute allure par
xavier jallais le futur alain prost est
peut-être dans les yvelines jim il ya
sept ans vient de remporter le
championnat de france et la coupe de
france dans la catégorie minikart 125
centimètres cubes le buhan courtois
devient par la même occasion le plus
jeune pilote de l'histoire à réaliser
cette performance
une précocité qui impressionne jimmy a
seulement débuté la compétition en
février dernier il est phénoménal
quand c'est pas parce que c'est mon
petit frère le convoi roulait c'est
impressionnant
déjà pour une première année comme ça
réussir à tout dernier c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'exceptionnel à 7 ans
c'est du jamais vu
les autres pilotes pasqua
elle est marquise de championnat 3 nuls
de mareuil disent que c'est moi de tenir
ses résultats jim elias que plusieurs
fois par semaine sur circuit à plus de
100 km sous les conseils de son frère
regardez toutes les traducteurs
donne toute la trajectoire le confort
hadji c'est que dès qu'on me dit quelque
chose directement le tour d'après il ne
fait donc ça c'est vraiment magique on
n'a pas besoin de passer toute une
journée sur un virage on peut passer
vite chaud suivante libinois s'inspire
également des pilotes de formule 1 la
discipline reine de course automobile
solide elle le britannique à lévis
centene triple champion du monde et la
gagner les courses comme moi la balle
échappait à dieu de france
il lâche un peu adulte du coup j'aime
bien je pense que ça peut être une belle
affluence ce sont de bons conseils
visuel pas mal de paramètres
effectivement l'épée s'enrichir qu'en
regardant les meilleurs amis tel est
l'un des meilleurs du monde
donc je pense que jouer a choisi la
belle
là
avant de penser à la formule an dans les
prochaines années jean elias rêve de
remporter le championnat du monde 2004
qui se tiendra du 15 au 22 octobre à
sarno en italie près de naples la
compétition réunira les 36 meilleurs
pilotes mondiaux de la catégorie
un mot d'athétisme à présent changement
la tête de l'entente athlétique de saint
quentin en yvelines le club qui compte
plus de 800 adhérents des années
présidée par jean pierre heuzé 28 ans
les sportifs intégrer le club en
septembre 2010 il remplace maximum et
qui dirigeait la structure depuis à 2003
on écoute un des projets du club c'était
un peu un nivellement au sein de rhodia
des bénévoles pour essayer de profiter
d' essayer d'avoir un peu de jeunesse
pour se préparer les transitions pour
les années à venir
mais c'est comme ça que j'ai été élu
vice-président et dans les traités max
avec son son travail
pour d'autres raisons avait beaucoup
moins de possibilités d'être sur le
terrain
on passe maintenant résultats du week
end
on commence s'est trouvée par du
football et le championnat de promotion
d'honneur l'équipe senior de trappes
débute mal à sa saison les joueurs
d'arles
abhisit se sont inclinés 2 buts 1 sur le
terrain de boussens ville ce dimanche
une contre performance pour le club qui
espère monter à cette saison au
classement trappe une neuvième du
championnat et jouera le 18 septembre
prochain contre-courant à domicile en
excellence il n'y avait pas que
l'empathie jouer à ce week end du en
cours saint quentin recevait verneuil à
domicile pour le compte de la première
journée et durant courtois se sont
apaisées à deux guitares et occupe la
quatrième place du championnat
de son côté à montillot boiteuse s'est
incliné à l'extérieur contre angers aux
benjamines 2 à 0 une nouvelle opération
pour le club qui devrait lutter pour ne
pas descendre cette année on passe
maintenant à l'agenda de la semaine
on commence est agendée à par me
thibault tenue du handball féminin
continue et reprend la compétition ce
samedi à 20h30
les intel le reçoivent saint-amand à
l'occasion de la première journée de
championnat de nationale 2 au gymnase
pierre de coubertin les versions
favorite de la rencontre à tenteront de
mettre à profit leur expérience de la
nationale 2 la saison passée pour
apporter à le match toujours en handball
plaisir jouait ce dimanche son premier
match de la saison en prénationale
masculine contre ça toi le mona les
plaisirs wa auront à coeur de monter
cette année après avoir échoué à la
deuxième place à trois années
consécutives
si vous voulez soutenir l'équipe peu le
match est programmé à 16 heures au
gymnase pierre de coubertin
il y aura également du football avec la
trouille le troisième tour de la coupe
de france celui en cours joie contre
persan une équipe du val d'oise ce
dimanche au stade maurice baquet le
match risque d'être serré les deux
équipes évoluent dans le championnat
excellence du golfe pour terminer cet
agenda le golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines va accueillir à partir de ce
jeudi la première édition du paris les
djeuns championship
plus de cinquante quatre champions et
anciens vainqueurs de tournois majeurs
sont présents pour ce rendez vous le
fantasque américain john delli sur a
notamment à présent le cercle nautique
de versailles étant daigle président du
club d'aviron à 2000 ans d'art est
décédé à l'âge de 50 ans le lundi à 15
août durant son vol qui le ramenait des
jeux olympiques de rio l'emblématique
figure de l'algérie vers ces vies
étaient allés soutenir la de cette
protégée de la baroque médaillé de
bronze pendant les jo on écoute la
réaction du rameur on est évidemment
très touché par ce décès c'est une
grande personnalité
mais laisser un grand vide puisqu'il
faisait beaucoup de choses je pense que
le qu'elles aient les moyens largement
de surmonter cette épreuve
c'est difficile pour tous ceux qui le
connaissaient pas ce que l'était
vraiment très attachant c'était vraiment
une personnalité extraordinaire nous a
bien falloir faire sans lui
ça va être le défi dès les prochaines
années c'est la fin de six sept huit
sports merci d'avoir suivi je vous
retrouve lundi prochain pour un nouveau
magazine la très belle soirée sur tv fil